Why can't you just stop it yourself? There's
no way you can accept that. You're so cruel and
cruel that you can't be considered a hero or even a human.  It
's you guys, are
n't you? In this room with no futon, you're planning to make Arasramus
sleep on the hard tatami mat.
If you really want to stop Araramus, you should at least change the futon. There's also such a wonderful
storage space, so that's the
place to store Urushibara.  I want to
say that I'm just a burden here.Anyway, I'm going to
organize the bottom shelf a little.When I go home,
I want to take the things that are in this Demon King's Castle with me.  You should be able to use a microwave
or refrigerator if you
ask for a power source.The
same goes for me.That's
not the case.Think about it.We're
devils.Don't laugh if we bring home a human-sized futon.Anyway, the
futon is...  You can't use it even if you bring it back to the other side.
And to be honest, you don't have any money. It's
been a year since you came to Japan. What did you do in the
winter? You were wearing
layers of clothes and sleeping under a kotatsu.
Even if you didn't do any subjugation, this year...  It seems like they'll invest their money in the winter. I ca
n't help it. I don't care what happens to you guys, but I'm concerned about the
ringworm, so I
'll give you half the money to buy a futon. We'll go buy one together.
Seriously.